our subject for this evening from darkness to
light what did i say from darkness to light
i am the true vine and my father is the husband
man every branch in me that beareth not fruit he
taketh away and every branch that beareth fruit he
purges it that it may bring forth more fruit now
you clean through the word which i have spoken
unto you abide in me and i in you as the branch
cannot bear fruit of itself except it abide in
the vine no more can ye except ye abide in me i
am the vine ye are the branches he that abideth in
me and i in him the same bringeth forth much fruit
for without me you can do nothing if a man
abide not in me he is cast forth as a branch
and is withered and men gathered them and
cast them into the fire and they are burned
if he abide in me and my words abide in you you
shall ask what he will and it shall be done unto
you hearing is my father glorified that you
bear much fruit so shall ye be my disciples
as the father hath loved me so have i loved you
continue ye in my love if ye keep my commandments
he shall abide in my love even as i have kept
my father's commandments and abide in his love
god is good and all the time let me read
john 15 10 again listen microscopically
he is speaking to the disciples and by extension
he's speaking to us if ye keep my commandments
he shall abide in my love the greek word for
abide means to remain or to stay you know the
bible says he that endureth unto the end the same
shall be saved if he keep my commandments he shall
abide remain in my love even as i have kept
my father's commandments and abide in his love
jesus kept in the father's
love by loving obedience
disobedience cuts us off from god
let me say it again but i let the
bible say if ye keep my commandments
you shall abide in my love says jesus that's
jesus and the disciples even as i have kept
my father's commandments and abide in
his love there is a catastrophic teaching
in christianity you come to christ it's a one-shot
thing and that's it you read john 15 1-10 there's
the concept of remain abide persist continue hold
on paul told timothy in first timothy 6 12 fight
the good fight of faith it's a constant battle the
half-brother of jesus james tells us in james 4 7
submit yourself therefore to god resist the
devil and he shall flee it's a constant warfare
but the power to fight victoriously is the
indwelling power of jesus christ elohwhite writes
in the desire of agsp 324 paragraph one we may
live off many habits for a time we may part
company with satan but without a vital connection
with god through surrender of ourselves to him
moment by moment we shall be overcome without
a personal communion or personal acquaintance
and a continual communion we are at the mercy
of the enemy and will do his bidding in the end
meaning there are some adventists sitting in
advent churches now not you who in the time of
trouble will work with the powers to persecute
the faithful and they're sitting in churches now
because they do not have a continual
communion and a moment by moment surrender
the relationship with christ
is never to be put on autopilot
it is a conscious experience i often say the
devil will wait 35 years just for the right
moment in your life when you drop your spiritual
guide just a moment to ruin a life and so moment
by moment is a very important concept well that's
not my sermon good evening everyone how are you
did you have a good day did the rain cause any
problems for you i wanted to go to the gym but
the rain fell incessantly and so i canceled that
plan i'll try tomorrow you know loi says it is
god's law that strength is acquired by effort it
is exercise that develops so the body and the mind
if you don't take care of your body it will
deteriorate it deteriorates anyhow with aging
but you can slow down the process by taking care
of yourself god did not put adam behind the desk
he put him in a garden well god bless all of you
behind desks don't get up and walk away tomorrow
but i just thought i would throw that in he put
him in a garden not behind a desk is there anyone
with us who is not a seventh-day adventist nice
your hand ah how very nice would you stand please
what's your name
rosemary is a very lovely name rosemary how are
you it is nice to see you where are you from
in baytown who invited you tonight and who is that
oh yes yes okay rosemary i'm very glad you've come
may god bless you bless your family and save you
when he comes let everybody say amen for rosemary
we'll be here again tomorrow night am i
right pastor rosemary i will look for you
tomorrow night do not break my heart all right
anybody else you're not a seventh-day adventist
oh that love oh please would you stand please we
ah yeah okay what's your name tammy and lovely
name tammy i have a little friend called tammy
how are you tammy how are you how are you how
are you oh no i don't have to ask that you're 16
how are you how are you good where are you from
where where else are you
from crosby is that close by
okay okay tammy i'm glad you've
come tell us who invited you
ah god bless you sister for being a busy person
tell me may the lord bless you take care of you
provide your needs and save you when he comes
say amen for tammy who came from her mother all
right anybody else anybody else you're not an
adventist we're delighted to have you really
are you could have decided to go somewhere else
you came to spend time with us and we're grateful
and for those of you at missouri city or at
born again if they're guests thank you very
much for coming and for those of you online
if there are non-seventh-day adventists online
watching may the lord doubly bless you i mean
that with all sincerity i wish i knew where those
online are with this united states or england
or kenya or wherever new york wherever you are
it is one god for this entire world can you say
amen what is it we sing this is my father's world
wherever you are there is god our subject
for this evening from darkness to light
what did i say from darkness to light remember
wherever you are preserve reverence it is easy
to be irreverent in the presence of god but let's
preserve reverence particularly if you're at home
where you're more casual and relaxed i'm not sure
if god is a relaxed person or casual person but uh
let's preserve reverence for him favor
number two while i'm speaking pray for me
all i want you to say is lord put your words
in that man's mouth and that man is not joking
ask god to put his words in my mouth i'll give
you two bible verses the one i normally give is
jeremiah 1 verse 9. then the lord put forth his
hand and touched my mouth and the lord said unto
me behold i have put my words in thy mouth when
god sent moses to speak to pharaoh here is what
god told moses exodus 4 verse 12 now therefore
go i will be with thy mouth and teach thee
what thou shalt say i want god to do that for me
i'll give you another verse ii samuel 23 verse 2
the spirit of the lord spake by me and his word
was in my tongue that's what i want favor number
three think isaiah 1 18 come now let us reason
together saith the lord it is a is you behave like
god when you think and you reason and god says i
will join you in that reasoning and if you do that
the lord will guide your reasoning in the path of
truth through the agency of the spirit of truth it
is now 7 30 on the dot i want to release you by 8
15 let us pray father bless this meeting to your
glory and to our blessing forgive me where i've
sinned forgive my brothers and sisters dear god
help us to listen to your word as if we're
listening to your voice because it is your voice
tell me precisely what to say how to say when
to say it bless everyone listening a particular
blessing on rosemary and tammy we're so glad
they've come and whoever else may be online who's
a guest bless those persons father remember those
listening who may have covered 19. i ask you their
father because you delight in mercy micah 7 18
touch them and restore them to full health i pray
bless the countries represented by those
listening their god bless the leaders guide
them that their decisions may be advantageous
to the gospel now their gods surround this place
with angels that excel in strength that they may
shield us from the influence of the wicked ones
thank you for the honor of speaking for you
in jesus name i pray amen what's our subject
from darkness to light go with me to isaiah
42 we'll read six and seven isaiah 42 6 and 7.
while i'm waiting for you to find it let me remind
some of you you need to make decisions for baptism
somebody needs to make a decision for re-baptism
because a life has not been what it should be in
a serious way only you and god know but the spirit
has been troubling you you need to start again and
take god seriously this time what book did i say
what chapter 42 what verse 6. i read from the king
james version of the bible the bible says i the
lord hath called thee in righteousness and will
hold thy hand and will keep thee and give thee
for a covenant of the people for a light of the
gentiles now this is the prophecy of the mission
that christ would come to carry out verse seven
to open what the blind eyes go on to the wall
bring out the prisoners come on from the
prison and them that sit in darkness out
from the prison house now we'll read that
verse again very closely microscopically
verse 7 what does it say to opened blind the
blind eyes now someone blind is in what condition
darkness darkness with all the
fleshlight the person is in darkness
to open the blind eye is to take
someone out of darkness spiritually
what is the next expression saying to bring
out the prisoners from the prison house from
prison they are from prison they are prisoners but
you'll discover that to open the blind eyes and to
bring out the prisoners are essentially
the same thing read the last statement
and them that sit in darkness out of the prison
house so we have darkness and prison in the last
statement we have them as two separate statements
at the beginning of the verse meaning to bring
someone out of darkness is to bring someone out
of prison because the darkness is the darkness
of error are you with me this is a prophecy of
what christ would come to do now go to isaiah 61.
isaiah 61 we'll read verse 1 and this is
the passage jesus quoted in his very first
well as luke records it public discourse in
the synagogue in luke chapter 4 we'll get
this shortly but now in isaiah 61 reading
verse 1 our subject from darkness to light
you have that the spirit of the lord god is upon
me because the lord hath anointed me to do what
preached glad tagged our good tidings unto the
meek he has sent me to bind up the brokenhearted
to the walk to proclaim liberty to the captives
finish that verse and opening of the prison
to them that are bound this is the mission of
christ it goes along with isaiah 42 7. let's read
it again the spirit of the lord god is upon me
because the lord hath anointed me to preach good
tidings unto the meek jesus said in luke 4 18 to
preach the gospel to the poor it's the same thing
keep reading to bind up the brokenhearted to
proclaim liberty to the now we read in isaiah
42 7 those in the prison house is the same thing
finished verse 1 of isaiah 61 and the opening of
the prison to them that abound now jesus said
the spirit has anointed me to open the prison
this is not sing-sing or alcatraz those
are not prisons compared to this prison
this was the mission of christ
to bring people out of prison
i want to tell you something
about the warden of this prison
go to isaiah 14. this prison has a warden
when you find out who he is you'll take
a sit up and take notice isaiah 14 we'll
read a little about a being that used to
be called lucifer but we now know him as
satan this is some biographical
information about the devil
isaiah 14 reading from verse 12. has anyone
said lord put your words in that man's mouth yet
not yet okay hurry up hurry up it doesn't take
long for the devil to get into the mouth of a
preacher and give him the wrong word let him
bite his tongue so i need to be shielded with
your prayers this is no joke however fallen
from heaven or lucifer's son of the morning
howarth thou cut down to the ground which this
weakened the nations now here's what lucifer said
that led to the rebellion in heaven for thou has
said in thine heart i will ascend into heaven
i will exalt my throne above the stars of god i
will sit also upon the mount of the congregation
in the sides of the north i will ascend above the
heights of the clouds i will be like the most high
keep this in mind i will be like the most
high go to isaiah 40. let's read for verse
25. isaiah 40 reading from verse 25. or just
verse 25 our subject from darkness to light
do you have isaiah 40 verse 25 are you there
read with me what does it say to whom then
will he liken me or shall i be equal saith
the holy one now who is the holy one verse
40 what does that say not verse 40 verse
26 lift up now then eyes and behold what
who hath created these things who is the holy
one the creator who is the creator jesus christ
now go back to isaiah 14 verse 14. the
last statement in verse 14 of isaiah 14 i
will be like the most high lucifer wanted
to take whose place the place of jesus
now you can't do that go to isaiah 45
isaiah 45 just read verse 22 of isaiah 45 do
you have that read with me look unto me come on
and be saved all the ends of the earth
finish the verse for i am and there is
read verse 18 of isaiah 45 for thus
said the law that created the heavens
god himself that formed the earth and made it he
hath established it come on he created it not in
vain he formed it to be inhabited finish
the verse i am the lord there's none else
you can be god-like you can be godly you cannot be
god we're called to be god-like we're called to be
godly we're called to reflect the character of god
through christ we receive the very righteousness
of god but we can never be god lucifer said i
will be like the most high go to verse 15 of
isaiah 14 as we continue from darkness to light
the first war was not in iraq it was in heaven
lucifer and satan a lucifer in christ by then
he was satan and christ you have verse 15 when
he said in verse 14 i will be like the most high
verse 15 says yet thou shalt be brought down to
hell to the size of the pit read carefully now
they that see thee shall narrowly look upon thee
and consider this saying is this the man that made
the earth to tremble that did what that destroyed
nations that made the world as a wilderness and
destroyed the cities thereof stopped now carefully
the last statement of verse 17. come on reed i'll
listen to you that opened not the house of ah
satan does not open his prison
house the prison houses sin
do you understand now why the bible
says the mission of jesus was to open
that prison house and bring people out let
me say differently when the devil has you
who can finish my words he does not let you go
whether he has you by drugs by alcohol by sexual
immorality by constant stealing whatever means
the devil when he has you he does not let you go
someone had to be sent more powerful than he
is to restrain him and release his captives
now let's go back to isaiah 42 let's read
verse 7 our subject from darkness to light
the only person who was sent
to do that give me his name
jesus christ without christ you can
be decent but you cannot be saved
you are you back to isaiah 42 verse 7 read with me
to open the blind eyes to bring out the prisoners
out of the prison and them that sit in darkness
out of the prison house that's why one of the
reasons jesus came to bring people out from
that prison from which they cannot release
themselves let me say it again you can be decent
without jesus you can be educated without jesus
you can be cultured without jesus you know what
wine goes with what fish and how to use a fork and
a knife which fork is for the salad and which is
for the vegetarian shrimp you can know all of that
are you with me and be lost
because only jesus can save you
having said that let's go to colossians one
it's a quarter to eight colossians one time
flies so quickly when you're in the pulpit
you have colossians who wrote colossians
paul yes you know paul was a murderer not by
physical action but by agreement and by arresting
people and handing them to the murderers and so he
said i consented to their death but he met christ
and became the greatest preacher after
christ i don't care what you are murderer
a thief whatever you let jesus touch you he
will change your life from north to south
what book did i say colossians what chapter one
reading from verse 12. are you there read with
me giving thanks unto the father which hath made
us meet to be partakers of the inheritance of the
saints in life now verse 13 carefully who hath
said careful who hath delivered us from what
from the power of come on say it again from
the power of darkness and have translated us
into the kingdom of his dear son now did we run
into darkness before in the verses we've read
yes isaiah 42 6 7 we ran into darkness darkness
is error no wonder jesus told the disciples
he is the light of the world a light of the
world now we just read who hath translated us
from the power of darkness who had delivered
us sorry from the power of darkness
and translated us into the kingdom of his dear
son go to acts 26 we read from verse 16 this is
some information about what jesus said to paul
when he struck him on the road to damascus that
incident is recorded three places in the book of
acts acts 9 acts 22 acts 26 we're looking at the
version in chapter 26 we read in verse 16. our
subject from darkness to light you have acts 26
verse 16 let me pray again dear god continue to
control me you have my permission control me 100
suppress my carnal nature and be glorified through
the presentation of truth in jesus name i pray
amen but rise and stand upon thy feet for i have
appeared unto thee for this purpose keep reading
to make thee uh minister and the witness both
of these things which thou has seen and of the
things in the which i will appear unto thee
now read verse 18 carefully first line two
stop what condition are they
in and what's that darkness
to open their eyes next statement two turn them
from darkness to is the same thing but it's
emphasized now here's the third statement same
thing third statement and from the power of unto
yes i will turn them from the power of satan
through paul of course i'll work through you
to turn people from the power of satan they
are caught in addictions and they view their
lives as useless jesus says no no no your life
isn't useless i came to fix that kind of life
your spouse left you whether the wife that left
the husband left three children mortgage whatever
your life you're about to take your life no no no
jesus christ let me tell you this says jesus the
things which are impossible with men are possible
with god and jesus says to that person who has who
has come to the end of his horror genesis 18 14 is
anything too hard for the lord give me the answer
no the hardest thing for god is not to get
you a job the hardest thing for god is not
to find you a spouse the hardest thing for god
is to get you away from sin because we love sin
you don't believe me let the bible tell you and
you'll believe it john 3 verse 19. john 3 19
12 minutes to 8. i'll say
enough by 8 or 8 15. don't worry
you know you ought to give people just a little
bit let them go home and think you can't overfeed
people with the bible or with rice or with
pastor you can't offer feed you understand
all right what book did i say what
chapter 3 verse 19 do you have it
i just said it's hard for god because we
love sin it's not easy to get someone away
from what he or she loves if you don't doubt me
try to get your child away from his or her phone
or ipad or ipod are you following me all right
read john 19 now and this john 3 19 come on and
this is the condemnation the light is coming to
the world stop what is light yes what is darkness
sin or error or prison yes then what is light
truth okay and this is the condemnation that
light or truth is coming to the world keep reading
now but men love darkness rather than light why
because the deeds were evil so god has a
hard time god has to perspire because he's
trying to pull us away from what we like so
we hold on to it and he's trying to drag us
god can get you a job like
that he got one for daniel
he got one for three hebrew boys he got a high
position for joseph that's not a problem for god
getting us from sin because sin is the very
power of satan and that's a challenge for god
but not a difficult he can conquer that if we will
cooperate with god now we have just found out that
satan does not open his prison we read that where
tell me isaiah 14 17. let's go see something else
or let's add to what we've said matthew 12 reading
from verse 22 let's see an example of someone who
who was delivered from the prison of satan matthew
12 verse 22 our subject from darkness to light
it's ten minutes to eight do you have matthew 12
and my friends online i hope you're still with us
and didn't switch the channel there's nothing on
tv better than the word of god somebody say amen
all right you have matthew 12 22 read
with me then was brought unto him one
possessed with the devil blind
and dumb and he healed him stop
look at that description again
then was brought unto him one
possessed possessed controlled
dominated taken over by a devil
blind and dumb the possession left him
blind and dumb remember the woman in
luke 5 who was bent over could not stand upright
jesus said in verse 16 satan had her that way
did not the devil put a disease on job from
the soul of his foot to the crown of his head
the devil can do that that you see that's a
negative miracle to just put a disease on someone
you understand what i mean by a negative
miracle to heal the person is a positive miracle
it's miraculous if i just struck you with
leprosy that'd be a miracle you're sitting
there nice and healthy and i just waved my hand
you turn white to snow the devil can perform
miracles that's why it is dangerous to choose
a church just because people said there was a
miracle come on say oh again okay there are
people who flock to churches there's a miracle
the devil can perform miracles but he cannot
preach truth the greatest proof that god is
present is not miracles it is thus saith
the lord when moses went to pharaoh did
he cast down his rod come on say yes or
no did the magicians cast down theirs
yeah they presume snakes however they did it
that's not the point it looked like the same thing
let me say it again miracles are no
reliable proof that god is present
people say they are slain in the spirit well
you've got to figure out what spirit am i slain by
because they're two let's go back to matthew 12
22 then was brought unto him one possessed
with the devil blind and dumb and
he healed him he fixed the problem what's
the next word stop what does in so much mean
to such an extent are you with me finish
the verse now that the blind and dumb
both spake and saw do you see two pairs of
opposites no don't look at me look at the verse
what are the two pairs of opposites blind and
saw come on dumb and speak what do you call that
what kind of a change do you call
that let's say you're going north
and you start going south what kind of a
change have you made uh opposite direction
okay and about faith bless you for having a
nice face who said about faith it's from not
the south that's what god wants to do for you
god doesn't change you from north to northeast
he changes it from north finish my words to south
that's conversion conversion doesn't make
you less worldly ah come on you don't
like me anymore conversion doesn't make
you less worldly it makes you spiritual
the problem is oh i won't tell you you won't like
me but i'll tell you most people are not converted
being convinced the seventh day is the
sabbath is not the same thing as conviction
you see an argument can convince you
only the spirit of god can convict you
there are many people in the church because they
were convinced i had no argument against it and
we're glad you're here we want you to move now to
conviction then was brought unto him one possessed
with the devil blind and dumb and he healed him
then was brought unto him one possessed by a
drug addiction and christ healed him in so much
that his friends could not recognize him anymore
go to matthew not matthew mark 5. what's your
subject mr light could you take those pictures
off the screen please i just realized they
were up there please take those things off
i'd be very happy and there's one down
there staring at me take him off too
i remember i'm quite serious i don't
yeah and you're a sinner you don't need to look
at yourself what book did i say mark what chapter
reading from verse 1 let me pray father as i
come to the down slope of the message please
continue to assist me in jesus name i pray amen
and they came over onto the other side of the sea
into the country of the gatherings and when he
was come out of the ship immediately they met
him out of the tombs a man with an unclean spirit
who had his dwelling among the tombs and no man
can bind him nor not with change because that
he had been often bound with fetters and chains
and the chains had been plucked asunder by him
and the fetus broken in pieces and neither can
any man tame him and day and night he was in the
mountains and the tombs read that description
for me crying and cutting himself with stones
terrible condition the devil does not like you
he'll give you things but he doesn't like you a
farmer who fattens up a cow for
the kill does not like that cow
and the devil gives you thing gives you things
he just threatens you for the kill when christ
gives you things he prepares you for the kingdom
or may i say when christ takes away some things
from you he prepares you to go through that narrow
gate you've got to drop off that backpack of sin
or you can't get through but once you get
through there is a paradise that lasts how long
forever and day and night he was in
the mountains and in the tombs crying
and cutting himself with stones verse 6 but when
he saw jesus say amen for jesus afar off he ran
and worshiped and cried with a loud voice and said
what read verse seven what did he say what if i to
do with thee thou what son of the most high god
are you journey by god that thou torment me not
that's interesting by the way you
know what the devil said to jesus
look at the verse what did he say to jesus
don't in me say that differently
don't hurt me don't hurt me
do you understand the power christ has
over demons the demon said don't hurt me
ah you're not listening you're nice looking but
you're not listening the demon said don't hurt me
satan and his demons understand the power of
jesus at any moment he can block them out the
demon said don't hurt me because he had said come
out of the man thou unclean spirit verse 9 and he
asked him saying what is thy name and he answered
saying my name is legion why for we are many
verse 10 and he besought him much
what does that mean he begged
he begged who's begging the demon is
beg listen to me get next to jesus
the demon begged him the all of them and he
besought him much that he would not send them away
out of the country verse 11 now there was there
nigh under the mountain a great herd of swine
feeding verse 12 what does that say and
all the devils what besought him saying
send us into the swine that we may enter
into them for thirteen and fourth with jesus
gave them leave come on and the unclean
spirits went out and entered the swine
and they ran finally down the steep place there
were two thousand and were drowned in the sea
jesus delivered someone who was
possessed to the point the person had
almost no consciousness of who he was bound
with chains and fetters he would break them
wandering in the mountains the tombs cutting
himself people would not pass that way
in darkness verse 15 a glorious verse read
that for me nice and clear and they came to
jesus and see him that was possessed with the
demon and had the legion walk sitting come on
clothes come on in his right mind stop somebody
needs to be put in his or her right mind
now you may not be on psychotropic medication
but in you're not in jesus you're not in your
right mind because you cannot be in your right
mind when you say no to life that's what jesus is
you cannot be in your right mind when you
say no the truth when truth alone sanctifies
a lot of well-dressed people who are not in their
right minds but tonight someone listening to me
can decide father i want to be in my right mind
and to be in your right mind you must seek the
feet of jesus he is the only one who can deliver
you from that prison cell over which the devil
is the warden now go to matthew 12 then we'll
close matthew 12. our subject is what quickly
from darkness to light matthew 12. let's
go back to 22 and read all the way down
when i ask you to read with me only
my sister up front reads with me
the rest of you you don't but i hope you'll do it
now i'm in the last passage are you with me let's
read then was brought unto him one possessed with
the devil blind and dumb and he healed him in so
much that the blind and dumbo spake and saw next
verse says what and all the people said what why
all the people were amazed and said
what is not this a miracle of god
presents god more clearly to those who
view it but verse 24 said what but when
pharisees they said well this fellow doth not cast
out devils but by beelzebub the prince of devils
here is the charge they charged jesus with using
the power of the devil to cast out the devil
that's when the bible says verse 36 for
every idol word that men shall speak
that was the idol word you understand me
it's not that if you say house that's an
idol no no in the bible very often the word
word refers to statement are you following me
they said this fellow doth not cast out devils
but by beelzebub the prince of devils now read
the next verse for me what does that say 25
and jesus knew there stop stop me all the
time but what does that verse say and jesus
knew their thoughts right now someone listening
to me is wavering between a decision for baptism
and perhaps pleasing a friend who does not
want them baptized jesus knows your thoughts
surrender that thought to him and say jesus father
move my mind in the direction of obeying you
he knows your thoughts right where you sit
and jesus knew their thoughts and said what
keep reading every kingdom divided against itself
is brought to desolation every city or house
divided against itself shall not stand now listen
very carefully to the next verse keep reading if
satan cast out satan he has defined it against
himself how shall then his kingdom stand stop
what does jesus say that satan has a kingdom
and jesus said if he fights against
himself his kingdom cannot stand
jesus acknowledges satan has
a kingdom but a kingdom isn't
just land because satan really has
no land a kingdom is mainly people
if satan cast out satan he
is divided against himself
how shall then his kingdom stand read
verse 27 what does that say but if i
cast out stop if i do what stop the only power
that can cast a demon out of you is jesus
and the demons know that the when the preacher
makes some statements he has to be very careful
i believe in health are you following me
a vegan diet does not cast out their satan
but don't stop eating one i just want to place the
emphasis where on jesus listen to me carefully a
dress that reaches down to the bottom of your
shoe does not cast out satan ah okay you're
laughing at the preacher that's dangerous the
only thing that casts out the devil is come on
jesus if that's clear say amen now read verse
27 now clearly and if i cast out devils by the
your trailer casama therefore they shall be
your judges now verse 28 but if i come on how
with the spirit of god then the kingdom of god
is come unto you so jesus said look i cast out
devils by the spirit of god now read verse 29
or else come on how can one enter into a strong
man's house and spoil his goods except he first
bind the strong man and then he will spoil his
house we have to reread that first there's some
strange words or else how can one enter into a
strong man's house who's the strong man satan
who had the fellow in verse 22 blind and dumb
jesus entered into his
house and delivered that man
how can one enter into strong man's house
and spoil his goods the word spoil means to
take away you know when you fight the
battle you're given the spoils you've
taken away to spoil in that verse is to take
away or else how can one enter into a strong
man's house and spoil his goods the goods
being the prisoners people except he first
bind a strong man how do you bind a strong man
with truth listen to this verse you don't have
to go and when the evil was come they brought
unto him many that were possessed with devils
and he cast out the spirit with his word
satan is bound by the word he has no power
over god's word and jesus declares himself to
be the stronger man that binds the strong man
and spoils his house meaning releases his captives
who are willing to leave you see jesus knocks
behold i stand at the door and knock
the devil crashes down the door jesus
knocks because you have to let jesus
know you really want to be saved
the devil doesn't care he just comes in
how can one enter into a strong man's house and
take away his captives people for whom christ died
except he first bind the strong man
time up and then he will spoil his house
jesus christ can deliver you from anything
in revelation 12 14 12 go there with me quickly
it's five after eight and i have a long flight
back to a missouri city so revelation 14
do you have that not yet verse 12.
revelation 14 and i'm closing i'm closing i
know preachers say that six and seven times
but i am closing revelation 14 verse 12. do you
have that now read with me please here is the
patience of the saints here are they that keep
the commandments of god and the faith of jesus
now listen to this statement selected messages
volume 3 page 172 paragraph 3 i'll give it again
selected messages volume 3 page 172 paragraph
three here's what the author writes the faith
of jesus what is it it is talked of but not
understood what constitutes the faith of jesus
that belongs to the third angel's
message and the author goes on to explain
jesus becoming our sin bearer that he might become
our sin pardoning savior he was treated the way
we deserve to be treated he came to our world and
took our sins that we might take his righteousness
and faith in his ability to save us amply
fully and entirely this is the faith of jesus
believing that jesus christ can
deliver you from any spiritual bondage
a lot of matthew he said no more verses go to
matthew 9 quickly quickly quickly are you there
come on i said quickly matthew 9 come on come
on and that's the last one okay let's read from
verse 27 of matthew 9 what's our subject from
darkness to light who alone can do that for
you jesus christ yes you have matthew 9.
let's read for verse 27 what does it say
and when jesus departed thence come on two blind
men followed him come on crying and saying what
thou son of david have mercy on us
what did they want to see read verse 28
when jesus was come into the
house the blind man came to him
and jesus saith to them now read what
jesus said very carefully read it belief
jesus didn't say do you believe i am going to do
that what did he say do you
believe i am able to do this
that's where the faith of jesus lies
do you believe that god has the ability
to stop you from drinking young man wrote me today
she said person i'm involved in masturbation and
pornography it has bothered me for years i get
these emails all the time he believe that god
is able to deliver him from that
that's the faith of jesus and the bible describes
a people at the end time who not only keep the
commandments of god but they have a faith in
the power of jesus to deliver them from anything
do you believe that jesus can
help you keep the sabbath yes
do you believe that christ can help you dissolve
that relationship that you should not be in
yes do you believe that christ can help you
return a tithe yes it's a reckless faith in
the eyes of the unbeliever it is trusting god
in the eyes of the believer the faith of jesus
from darkness to light there is no need for any
of us to continue in bondage to satan will he
bother you as long as you're on this earth does
he control your life no did he bother jesus
yes did he control christ no did he bother paul
yes the devil's business is to bother you your
business is to hold on to jesus i closed the book
to let you know i'm serious i'm done but you have
a decision to make there's some area of your life
where you need deliverance i'm not talking of that
television stuff where people wear their arms
and people fall down i'm not talking about that
i mean i don't mean deliverance from your money
you see that's what that is i mean deliverance
from sin there's someone listening to me whether
in this building or online you need deliverance
from something you need to move from darkness
to light in a particular area of your life
and i want you to turn that area over to jesus the
only one who can deliver you in bible commentary
volume 5 page 10 83 paragraph one the writer
gives these words bear in mind that it is none
but god that can hold an argument with satan not
you not your phd not your governmental position
jesus surrender that area of your life to christ
regardless of your age believe that jesus is able
to pull you from darkness to life to heal your
disobedience to your parents and make you a
respectful child he can do that because that's
what he was how many will say father there's an
area where i need victory i surrender that to you
can i see your hand just raise it stand with me
christ knows what it is i don't need to know
those of you online do the same thing please
there's an area you're surrendering to christ he
is able to do it when the blind man said yeah lord
jesus said according to your faith beat unto you
heads bowed eyes closed father there are people
listening to me struggling with one addiction one
trap one satanic prison situation after another
and they need deliverance they need to be brought
from darkness to light from the power of satan
to the power of christ and father that power to
effect that deliverance is jesus christ himself
who won the battle in heaven when the
devil rebelled against you who won the
battle on earth when he never sinned who won
the battle in the grave when he raised himself
in the name of this jesus their god convict
someone to turn over that life to christ who
died for that person help us to see father that
victory is available to us through an entire
surrender to christ and father convict someone
to make a decision for baptism or re-baptism
let not that person put it off until
tomorrow night's message we only have tonight
our heads about and eyes are closed i'm speaking
to everyone wherever you are in this building at
born again or at missouri city or online if
you will decide for baptism or re-baptism
make a note of that somehow and inform the church
leaders but for those of you in my presence if
you will make that decision tonight can i see your
hand you've not yet made it you've not yet made it
but you want to make it i'll give you 15 seconds
that's all say lord i am just making the decision
to be baptized or revamped if you're
shy tell the pastor after the service
wherever you are and you make that intelligent
decision let the church leaders know father
i close the service now but i know you will
not close the door of mercy continue to trouble
those who need to be troubled give them no
rest until they decide in favor of jesus
thank you for sending your son who alone can
deliver us from the power of darkness to light
from the prison of satan to freedom in christ
as we leave let us reflect on what we've heard
i pray take everyone home safely bring us back
tomorrow day god in jesus name we pray let god's
people say amen and amen we sing one stanza
of our closing hymn sing them over again to me
wonderful words of life let me more of
the beauty see wonderful words of life
words of life and beauty teach me faith and duty
beautiful words wonderful words wonderful words
wonderful words wonderful words of love now by the
grace of our lord jesus christ and the love of god
and the fellowship of the holy spirit be with
us now and forevermore let god's people say amen
and amen the pastor has a few words to make
no okay please travel safely keep the speed
limit because the christian should be
the best citizen on the face of the
earth
you